so a couple weeks ago we talked about
NATO today we're going to talk about G20
what's the difference between the two
who is World economic Forum why are
these guys in G20 the 20 countries
getting together in New Delhi to have a
meeting the theme was called one
Earth One future and the discussions
points were around climate change Health
Care food security and digitalization
what do they mean by digitalization do
they want to create one currency that we
all use and then do they score us on who
votes the right way what we drive how we
eat how we live who knows we're going to
talk all about that
[Music]
today so if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
G20 it started in
1999 the original Inception of it was
after the Asian financial crisis as a
forum for the finance Ministries and
Central Bank Governors to discuss global
economic and financial issues so G20
NATO World economic Forum G20 is is
different than NATO NATO's military G20
is economy then G20 is different than
World economic form because G20 is
government World economic form is
private companies just so kind of you
know the difference between what these
guys are so who is part of the G20
members and why did two countries not
show up to this year's G20 Summit the
G20 members are Argentina Australia
Brazil Canada China France Germany India
Indonesia Italy Japan Mexico Republic of
Korea Russia Saudi Arabia South Africa
turkey United Kingdom us and EU and two
countries didn't show up and I bet you
can guess who those two countries are
Russia and China didn't show up to this
year's G20 Summit now how big is G20 how
much influence do these guys have here's
what it looks like they account for
about 80% of world's GDP and 75% of
global trade G20 countries are home to
60% of world population combined
population of over 4.9 billion people
combine GDP over $150 trillion hence
digitalization imagine the influence
they have of $150 trillion they get to
say if we want to have one currency that
you and I have to lose they got enough
power and influence to be able to pull
that off it may take them 5 10 15 20
years but they're going to pull it off
if that's what they want to do because
they got that kind of influence 80% of
world's greenhouse gases they're
responsible for about 75% of world's
military spending G20 has been
criticized for its lack of transparency
and accountability and they been
criticized for its inability to reach
consensus on important issues and
despite these criticism G remains an
important forum for international
cooperation on economic issues so
remember earlier when I talked you about
the fact that the theme was one Earth
one family one future and they had these
different bullet points I want to talk
about there was a 70h pay document
called the G20 policy recommendations
for advancing Financial inclusions and
productivity gains through digital
public infrastructure key words let me
say it again advancing Financial
inclusion that's not the most friendly
word inclusion there's a part of force
in there it sounds Noble but it ends up
being through Force to include you
whether you like it or not so obviously
the interest rates right now are a
little bit weird they're crazy one day
they're 7.12 you're seeing all these
numbers for people that want to get Al
loan some people can't even get a loan
if you're somebody that wants to get a
credit line up to $250,000 the sponsor
today fund and grow can help you
possibly do that the great thing about
fund and grow is even in today's economy
they're able to get you a line of credit
which is hard to do with a lot of banks
they offer a 12-month membership that
gives small businesses an alternative to
traditional funding or gathering
investors they offer a way to get the
operating Capital you need without
having to deal with the current tedious
and confusing red tape at Banks they
help secure credit up to $250,000 at 0%
interest all without giving up any
Equity of your company these guys have a
great reputation with over
45.9 reviews online and for our
listeners they have prepared a special
business funding master class that will
uncover the five steps their clients
have used to secure up to $250,000 in
business cash and an exclusive $500
discount for their services go to
funding grow.com pbd again fund and
spelled out fnd D andd grow.com pbd for
more information and then productivity
gains through what digital public
infrastructure what are they talking
about with DPI like digital public
infrastructure the acronym DPI was used
441 times the term Financial inclusion
was used ready 263 times digital ID 83
times government to person payments 24
times one more time government toperson
payments 24 times do they want one
government if they're able to get one
currency what can they do with this what
level of control can they have that's
something some people are concerned
about because it lacks transparency and
accountability so again what's DPI
digital public infrastructure
interoperable open and accessible
infrastructure supported by technology
to provide essential society-wide public
and private Services digitally such as
identific ific ation payments and data
exchange they didn't say
decentralized this says centralized
there's a big difference between being a
centralized or decentralized so Bitcoin
one of their biggest things that people
would talk about is the fact that
decentralized where it's kind of like a
government's not controlling you there's
going to be control cuz obviously this
is all these 20 members controlling that
currency so so that's the DPI part but
let's talk about the government to
person payments remember how they use
that phrase 24 times what is government
to person payment look at the statistics
so here's some context globally
government to person g2p payments have
increased significantly in scale as if
that's a good thing government to person
has significantly scaled look at the
numbers in 2021 over a quarter of adults
were receiving payments from the
government an increase of 400 million
individuals from just four years earlier
not not 40 years earlier four years
earlier 400 million more people were
receiving payments from the government
on average in the past decade across a
sample of 46 developing countries with
available data 1.5% of GDP was allocated
to social assistant payments 3.6% to
pensions 7.3% to public wages and they
talk about how coid 19 help accelerate
the process in their paper they say in
2020 in response to the coid 19 crisis
spending on social protection programs
increased even further to at least 80
billion dollars across developing
countries So Co 19 beautiful thing for G
20 because it allowed them to increase
their 400 million more people getting
governmentt person payments The
increased scale of g2p payment programs
offers a huge opportunity to advance
ready Financial inclusion contribute to
women's economic empowerment and promote
the development of the digital ecosystem
again more of the same inclusion stuff
that they now want to push down people's
throats worldwide I'm not going to read
the whole thing but I'll give you a
couple of them here here's another one
for you leveraging dpis dpis can enable
digitalizing g2p payments in an
efficient inclusive again and adaptive
way in the following areas beneficiary
accounting opening account registration
with government program generating
payment instruction payment cash out or
digital use watch this year
jurisdictions that had in place dpis
such as digital ID digital payment
systems and infrastructure for data
sharing were also able to reach more
beneficiaries generally respond in a
faster more targeted and transparent
manner during what the pandemic the
pandemic was the best thing for the
people that wanted to impose cbdc they
love the pandemic cuz It sped up their
process look you if you want to get into
this you can I'm not going to read the
whole thing in this episode here but I'm
going to read this thing to you again
indeed according to the 2021 Global fex
865 million account owners in
development economies opened their First
Financial account for the purpose of
receiving government transfers during
what the pandemic so so to kind of put
in some context where it makes sense you
think about your state may have a
welfare program your your your state may
have some entitlement programs where
there's a state welfare state tax you
know these things that you do now
imagine the country has a entitlement
program welfare the country has a tax
now imagine Global welfare Global Tax
and then if there's a scoring system to
reward you or punish you based on
certain behavior that you may have that
doesn't match with climate change that
doesn't match with what they consider
healthy that's a little bit disturbing
for the people that love freedom and if
you watch this content you're somebody
that loves Freedom so watch this policy
recommendations I'll continue enable and
Foster the responsible use of dpis to
accelerate Financial inclusion and
productivity gains public authorities
could leverage dpis across public sector
programs and National strategies as well
as harness private sector capabilities
through collaborative approaches for
rapidly advancing Financial inclusion L
growth they have two key considerations
the first one is public public
authorities could consider developing
and harnessing dpis in their National
strategies and road maps on financial
inclusion digital economy and related
areas here's a second one that's the
kicker public authorities may lead by
example through fostering use of dpis in
public programs such as benefit
transfers social protection programs and
development Finance programs cbdc our
own currency that we get to control
development Finance programs as well as
their internal operations and processes
including in interactions between
individuals and businesses and the
government so now okay let's set that
aside saying it's all Noble good things
that they want to do uh one of the
organizations that was there which is
the bis was established in 1930 it is
owned by 63 central banks it stands for
the bank of international settlements
representing countries from around the
world that together account for about
95% of the world GDP now here's who bis
is so imagine the Federal Reserve what
the Federal Reserve is to us bis is to
the world so they kind of can dictate
some of the things that can happen to
the world economy the bis most recent
cbdc survey covered a record 81 central
banks representing close to 76% of the
world's population and 94% of the global
economic output this is the bis 2022
report Sur found out that nine out of 10
central banks are now exploring cbdc
half developing or running concrete
experiments the survey also showed that
more than two-thirds of central banks
are likely to issue a retail cbdc in the
shortterm or the midterm which is within
the next 6 years the Atlantic Council
2023 separately tracks cbdc developments
in 100 19 countries and indicate similar
results over 40 countries have
approached the IMF to request assistance
through cbdc capacity development and by
the way some people say come on Pat you
know digital ID what are you talking
about this is not going to happen I mean
it's not like during Co EU didn't take
on a digital ID and a passport while you
were traveling for people to know you
had taken the vaccine oh no they did do
that really so when I would go to the
airport I had to show them this digital
passport so they could see that I took
the vaccine yes okay Pat what's wrong
with that well you know cbdc their own
digital currency uh more ways for me to
control what you're doing what you're
not doing so then the question becomes
for you is what level of privacy are you
willing to give up what level of privacy
are you willing to give up you may say
what do you mean by that what level of
questions do you think you're
comfortable with your boss knowing about
you what what what questions are you not
comfortable with it you know it's so
weird in America they're like well you
know you can't ask an employee when
you're interviewing them certain
questions yeah but the government can
know if I took a vaccine or not while
I'm traveling for what yeah but so so
this thing they push and you're like no
way I'll never do that and then you do
okay they listen they're willing to
conform they push no way I'll never do
that then you do cuz you're like oh my
God I feel so judged by my co-workers if
you don't take this you're not a
responsible
person oh my God and then they introduce
us no way now imagine their vision is to
come here right but they
go and gradually and all of a sudden
you're like no way I did all of it I
give up all my privacy exactly that's
what some people are uncomfortable with
and I bet you are too so final thoughts
here before we wrap up remember how
earlier we talked about the bis which is
like the Federal Reserve of the world
the bank of international settlements
they gave a report and there's one thing
that's a little bit also disturbing for
you to be thinking about you know as a
parent we program our kids and we
incentivize what for our kids to do and
what for them not to do you may
discipline them in a different way you
take away their IP you take away a toy
you take away certain car phone whatever
may be right but there's a reward
punishment for it that's fine as a child
totally get it do you think at 42 years
old a bis should be doing that to
tokenizing on how you vote you know what
kind of car you drive the decisions you
make well watch the word bis uses on
their report I want you to read this
here with me tokenization of money and
assets has great potential but
initiatives to date have taken place in
silos without access to central bank
money in the foundation of trust it
provides look at the second one is the
main one we're going to focus on here
right now a new type of financial Market
infrastructure a unified Ledger could
capture the full benefits of
tokenization by combining central bank
money tokenized deposits tokenized
assets on a programmable platform
programmable platform programmable I
program you okay programmable they
program you on your behaviors how you
vote maybe what vaccines you've taken
maybe all of these things programmable
and then all of a sudden somebody gets
more benefits than another person based
on who is following the government's
guidelines better who's following the
world the bis report that's being given
out that all these G20 members are using
I don't know about that by the way I
want you to know this I'm not sitting
here telling you these are all dark
people that want to come and take over
and ruin your life I'm not telling you
that are there some people that are
driven by evil and power and control
that are at these G20 Summits of course
I'm not sitting here disputing that but
I also think some of them are there for
the right reason what I am willing to
tell you is the following I lean on
being paranoid and trusting after
verifying and seeing what their motives
are and historically governments don't
have a track record on what they do with
power because somebody may come up with
some good ideas at first and that that
they're Noble but eventually somebody
may rise up that comes after them who is
not Noble they're driven by power and
they end up ruining people's lives
you've read about it you've watched many
videos you've seen many documentaries
won't be the first time it's best you
and I stay paranoid and keep watching
what these guys are doing at these big
meetings so if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel and if you don't know a lot
about cbdc you're like Pat I want to
learn more about cbdc click on the link
here to watch the video take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye